I get on the show or I get to Pierce
Morgan and about 10 minutes before the
show they switched the guests so I was
originally supposed to go on with a guy
that wrote a book about freedom of
speech then they switched it to someone
that was anti-Semitism now this this
rang a few alarm bells in my head
because you know I recently had this
video on Twitter go viral that was
really about yay getting kicked off of
all social media and he wasn't the only
one that's been kicked off but you know
I was freestyling on my guitar I was
just you know and the thing was I had
like 10 different songs that I put out
but this one it was like a freestyle
where I talked about cancel culture and
when yay said something like about the
Holocaust basically everyone freaked out
and kicked him out